all is this keep the faith we won't stop
until you are home
now with that now with that
um we have as you know the National
Security advisor to the president Jake
Sullivan who is going to give a preview
of his trip to the NATO Summit as you
all know starting on Sunday and take any
other questions that you may have okay
Podium is yours
good afternoon everybody thanks for
bearing with me today I'm going to
start by laying out the plan for the
trip that's upcoming this weekend and
then because there have been numerous
reports on the provision of cluster
Munitions to Ukraine I'll say a few
words on that at the top and then be
happy to take your questions
President Biden said on day one of his
administration that the United States
would Revitalize our alliances and
re-engage with the world to meet the
great challenges of our time and on
Sunday the president will depart for his
next major trip overseas at a time when
we have indeed regained our Global
standing as a strong and trusted partner
for peace progress and security
this trip will reflect that progress and
it will showcase the president's
leadership on the world stage
first the president will travel to the
United Kingdom while in London he will
meet with King Charles at Windsor Castle
and engage with a forum that will focus
on mobilizing climate Finance especially
bringing private Finance off the
sidelines for clean energy deployment
and adaptation in developing countries
people also meet with prime minister
sunac to consult on a range of bilateral
and Global issues next the president
will travel to penis Lithuania to attend
the NATO Summit
this will take place against the
backdrop of Russia's Russia's continuing
brutal war against Ukraine he will hold
a bilateral meeting with Lithuanian
president now Seda he will then meet
with all of the NATO leaders at the
summit as well as a number of NATO
Partners from Europe and from the
indo-pacific
they will discuss a range of subjects
from strengthening NATO's Eastern flank
to modernizing NATO's deterrence and
defense capabilities
thanks in large part to President
Biden's leadership NATO is stronger more
energized and more united than ever NATO
is also larger than ever with Finland
having joined the alliance and Sweden
soon to follow
this is important for the security and
safety of the American people because a
strong NATO makes the United States and
the entire world more safe and more
secure
at the summit the president and our
allies will demonstrate our unity and
resolve in support of Ukraine
when President Putin launched this war
he expected that Western Unity would
fracture that NATO would break that our
support to Ukraine would wither over
time
he was wrong
the United States has built a coalition
of dozens of countries from Europe to
the Middle East to the indo-pacific to
help Ukraine defend against Russian
aggression and we have mobilized the
security assistance Ukraine needs
including by facilitating contributions
from partners and allies around the
world so that Ukraine is in the best
possible position to succeed on the
battlefield we continue to stand with
the people of Ukraine as they defend
their sovereignty their freedom and
their democracy
after the summit President Biden will
give a significant address in Vilnius
that evening Wednesday evening about his
vision of a strong confident America
flanked by strong confident allies and
partners taking on the significant
challenges of our time from Russia's
aggression in Ukraine to The Climate
crisis
finally the president will travel to
Helsinki Finland where he will meet with
the president of Finland Minister and
participate in a U.S Nordic leader
Summit in these meetings the president
will advance our close cooperation with
the Nordic countries on shared Regional
security objectives along with shared
efforts on technology Health climate and
clean energy so we're looking forward to
a busy week in Europe and we're looking
forward to the president being able to
further solidify strengthen and give
momentum to the strong United Alliance
that has been standing up so effectively
against Russian aggression
as I mentioned because we've seen all of
these reports on the provision of
cluster Munitions to Ukraine I will
leave it to the Pentagon to make a
formal announcement later this afternoon
for the next drawdown package and to go
into the details of that drawdown
package and the specifics on the types
of Munitions being provided but I will
use this opportunity here today to make
a few points
first we base our security assistance
decision on Ukraine's needs on the
ground and Ukraine needs artillery to
sustain its offensive and defensive
operations artillery is at the core of
this conflict Ukraine is firing
thousands of rounds a day to defend
against Russian efforts to advance and
also to support its own efforts to
retake its Sovereign territory
we have provided Ukraine with a historic
amount of unitary artillery rounds and
we are ramping up domestic production of
these rounds we've already seen
substantial increases in production but
this process will continue to take time
and it will be critical to provide
Ukraine with a bridge of supplies while
our domestic production is ramped up we
will not leave Ukraine defenseless at
any point in this conflict period
second Russia has been using cluster
Munitions since the start of this war to
attack Ukraine
Russia has been using cluster Munitions
with high dud or failure rates of
between 30 and 40 percent
in this environment Ukraine has been
requesting cluster Munitions in order to
defend its own Sovereign territory the
cluster Munitions that we would provide
have dud rates far below what Russia is
doing is is providing not higher than
2.5 percent
and third we are closely coordinating
with Ukraine as it has requested these
Munitions Ukraine is committed to
post-conflict demining efforts to
mitigate any potential harm to civilians
and this will be necessary regardless of
whether the United States provides these
Munitions or not because of Russia's
widespread use of cluster Munitions we
will have to continue to assist Ukraine
with demining efforts no matter what
given the significant use of cluster
Munitions already perpetrated by Russia
so the bottom line is this
we recognize that cluster Munitions
create a risk of Civilian harm from
unexploded ordinance this is why we've
the defer deferred the decision for as
long as we could
but there is also a massive risk of
Civilian harm if Russian troops and
tanks roll over Ukrainian positions and
take more Ukrainian territory and
subjugate more Ukrainian civilians
because Ukraine does not have enough
artillery that is intolerable to us
Ukraine would not be using these
Munitions in some foreign land this is
their country they're defending these
are their citizens they're protecting
and they are motivated to use any weapon
system they have in a way that minimizes
risks to those citizens
so with that I would be happy to take
your questions Annie thank you so much
Journal I was hoping on
news earlier this week and that the
Russians may be open to a prisoner swap
for of enforcements and I also had a
question
um
for you about how the uprising by the
Wagner group May in your view impact
Russia's leaders willingness or lack
willingness
um to make a deal that would release
Evan so first as Karine mentioned before
today is the hundredth day of Evan's
unjust and unlawful detention and for
those hundred days President Biden the
entire National Security team our
Embassy in Moscow or Secretary of State
my self-personal personally have been
invested in trying to bring him home
safely second I had the opportunity this
morning to meet with Evan's employers at
the Wall Street Journal and uh the
personal representatives of his family
to talk about the latest status in his
case and our efforts to bring Evan home
third we did see the comments from the
Kremlin that there have been contacts
between the U.S and Russia regarding
Evan and other unjustly detained
Americans it is true and we have said
that we remain in contact with Russian
authorities at high levels on these
cases to try to figure out a way to
bring unjustly detained Americans home
including Evan we have also made clear
for months now even before Evan was
detained as we were dealing with Paul
Whelan that we are prepared to do hard
things in order to get our citizens home
including getting Evan home I do not
want to give false hope what the Kremlin
said earlier this week is correct there
have been discussions uh but those
discussions have not
produced a clear pathway to a resolution
and so I cannot stand here today and
tell you that we have a clear answer to
how we are going to get Evan home all I
can do is tell you that we have a clear
commitment and conviction that we will
do everything possible to bring him home
with respect to the question of whether
the recent actions by pregosian and the
Fallout from that creates new openings
or opportunities I can't say that I have
perceived that directly but of course
this is a story that continues to be
written day by day so we will have to
see how things continue to play out in
Moscow in the meantime we're going to
stay laser focused on doing everything
we can both directly with the Russians
and then with other allies and partners
around the world who are invested in his
safe return to try to get him out as
soon as possible yeah uh president
zielinski said an invitation for Ukraine
to join NATO will be the ideal outcome
from the summit why does the industry
believe that's not the right approach
well as you know the United States
strongly supports the open door policy
which says that Ukraine and NATO can
make a decision together about its
pathway towards membership and Vilnius
will be an important moment on that
pathway towards membership because uh
the United States our NATO allies in
Ukraine will have the opportunity to
discuss the reforms that are still
necessary for NATO for Ukraine to come
up to Nato standards so this will in
fact be a milestone but Ukraine still
has further steps it needs to take
before membership
Ukraine will not be joining uh NATO
coming out of this Summit we will
discuss what steps are necessary as it
continues along the classification what
commits president was the right time to
do class positions given the concerns
the Allies Express concerns to him and
are you suggesting that the reason
you're providing class magicians because
Ukraine is running out of unitary
artillery rounds is it is it the
backfill that so uh first we have been
looking at this for quite some time and
what we have been weighing is this basic
question of Civilian harm the challenge
of cluster Munitions as you know is that
even at low dud rates there are some
unexploded ordinance that is left and
that could potentially pose a risk to
civilians down the road so we did not
immediately come out of the gate and
provide this but we had to balance that
against the risk to civilian harm if
Ukraine did not have sufficient
artillery ammunition we are reaching a
point in this conflict because of the
dramatically High expenditure rates of
artillery of artillery by Ukraine and by
Russia where we need to build a bridge
from where we are today to when we have
enough monthly production of unitary
rounds that unitary rounds alone will
suffice to give Ukraine what it needs so
as a result this is the moment
to begin the construction of that bridge
so that there isn't any period over this
summer or heading into this fall when
Ukraine is short on artillery and being
short on artillery it is vulnerable to
Russian counter attacks that could
subjugate more Ukrainian civilians that
is the thinking behind our decision we
consulted closely with allies in
deciding to do this and some allies who
are not signatories to the Oslo
convention embraced it with open arms
that this is absolutely the right thing
to do even allies who were signatories
to the Oslo convention while they cannot
formally support something that they've
signed up to a convention against have
indicated both privately and many of
them publicly over the course of today
that they understand our decision and
fundamentally that they recognize the
difference between Russia using its
cluster Munitions to attack Ukraine and
Ukraine using cluster Munitions to
defend itself its citizens and its
Sovereign territory so we feel that this
will in no way disrupt the very very
strong firm Unity that we have heading
into the NATO Summit in Vilnius next
week thanks Jake to follow up on the
cluster Munitions last year in March the
U.S ambassador to the United Nations she
describes those Munitions as quote
exceptionally lethal Weaponry which has
no place on the battlefield so how do
you square those comments with this
decision and secondly has Ukraine
provided you with any assurances or
guarantees in terms of their use in
civilian areas that they won't use them
within a certain radius of Civilian
areas for example so uh Ukraine has
provided written assurances that it is
going to use these in a very careful way
that is aimed at minimizing any risk to
civilians and by the way Ukraine the
democratically elected government of
Ukraine has every incentive
to minimize risk to civilians because
it's their citizens it's ukrainians who
they are trying to protect and defend
this is not Ukraine taking these and
going and using them in the Middle East
or in Southeast Asia or in some far away
land they're using them on their
territory to defend their territory so
we believe that they are highly
motivated to do this and Beyond being
highly motivated they have to directly
answer your question provided these
assurances to us in terms of uh the
ambassador's comments and other comments
that have been bandied about let me just
say that the use of cluster Munitions by
Russia in this conflict is completely
unacceptable on multiple counts first
they are using them to attack a
sovereign country in flagrant violation
of international law second they are
using them specifically to strike after
civilian targets not only military
targets also in flagrant violation of
international law and with this weapon
system as well as other weapon systems
we have identified war crimes committed
by the Russians third and critically
there is a big difference between the
type of cluster munition being used by
Russia and the type that we would
provide to Ukraine as I mentioned before
ours have a maximum 2.5 percent dud rate
the dud rate of the Russian Munitions is
between 30 and 40 percent and just so I
don't get this wrong I I will read it to
you
the Department of Defense assesses that
during the first year of the conflict
alone Russian fired cluster Munitions
deployed from a range of weapon systems
have likely expended tens of millions of
submunitions or bomblets in Ukraine and
then the final point I think this is an
important point when I talk about what
Russia is doing with cluster Munitions
I'm not making an argument which says
they do it so we'll do it
the argument I'm making is that Russia
has already spread tens of millions of
these bomblets across Ukrainian
territory so we have to ask ourselves is
Ukraine's use of cluster Munitions on
that same land
actually that much of an addition of
Civilian harm given that that area is
going to have to be demined regardless
so that is why when we look at the
situation today as opposed to a year ago
and when we look at what Ukraine would
be doing with these weapons as opposed
to what Russia is doing with these
weapons we see a substantial difference
it doesn't make it an easy decision and
I'm not going to stand up here and say
it is easy it's a difficult decision
it's a decision we deferred it's a
decision that required a real hard look
at the potential harm to civilians and
when we put all of that together there
was a unanimous recommendation from the
National Security team and President
Biden ultimately decided in consultation
with allies and partners and in
consultation with members of Congress to
move forward on this step and Jake are
you satisfied with the pace and progress
of the Ukrainian counter offensive thus
far we get this question a lot I'm not
grading or judging the Ukrainian counter
offensive I'm standing here in
Washington D.C I'm not on the
battlefield my life's not on the line so
for me to sit here and say I'm satisfied
I'm not satisfied what I would say is
that it is hard going the Russians are
dug in they have thrown a lot of Defense
in Manpower and Munitions at this and
the ukrainians have bravely
systematically been punching and pushing
forward and will continue to do so the
ukrainians also have a substantial
amount of capacity they have not yet
committed to this fight so the story of
this counter offensive is far from
written and we will continue to support
Ukraine along the way yes Ukraine
provided written assurances for how they
would use these Munitions when was that
provided and also can you just provide
more details on what are those
assurances so they provided them in the
context of their written requests to us
for these Munitions so they reached out
and requested them I couldn't give you
the exact date but some weeks ago and in
doing so the assurance that they
provided was that they intend to use
these Munitions in a way to minimize the
exposure of civilians so outside of
Civilian areas and outside of areas that
civilians traffic
that is to say on the battlefield where
they are presently both trying to defend
their territory uh and to uh move
forward Are there specific locations
though red lines and those assurances or
did the administration advise them you
know only ongoing conversation because
obviously the battlefield is Shifting at
all times so it's impossible to set down
a map and and Define this with the level
of specificity that maybe your question
implies but it does mean that this
conversation needs to be ongoing just as
it as it is with every other weapon
system that we're providing Ukraine and
so far we have found that when Ukraine
provides assurances to the United States
about the use of its Munitions it is
followed through on that in terms of the
limitations and constraints it's placed
on those and we expect the same in this
case and I just want to underscore again
I know I sound like a broken record but
the idea that Ukrainian men and women
fighting for the Armed Forces of Ukraine
want to willy-nilly use these things in
a way that are going to harm Ukrainian
citizens which is somewhat implied in
the questions I find
um you know at odds with
their fundamental desire to protect
their countrymen and their willingness
to put their lives on the line to
protect their
countrymen's location I do not yeah
follow up on Ukraine and then I have a
second question related to that is it
the U.S view that President zielinski
should attend the NATO Summit and how
might his presence affect the outcome of
discussions so we would welcome
president zielinski at the NATO Summit
President Biden would welcome the
opportunity to meet with president
zielinski at the NATO Summit the NATO
Summit will dive into the question of
NATO's relationship with Ukraine both
the question of its pathway towards
future membership and the question of an
ongoing partnership that has existed for
several years and there will be
important practical announcements in
that regard at the summit so President
zielinski's
attendance at it would be very much
welcome back to Belarus I'm sorry
Eastern European nations want NATO
allies to beef up their security on the
Eastern Flint especially with Mr pergo's
expected Exile in the vaginal groups
expected Exile into Belarus which shares
a border with Lithuania is the U.S
planning to announce any new security
guarantees at The Summit we have the
Ultimate Security guarantee for Poland
and the Baltic states and it's Article 5
of NATO and we are in we intend to
defend every single inch of NATO
territory we've also put our money where
our mouth is in terms of enhanced U.S
deployments in both Poland and the
Baltic states as well as Romania and
other Eastern flank allies I had the
opportunity this morning to meet with my
counterpart from Poland the Polish
national security advisor the first and
main topic of conversation was the
evolving threat from Belarus both this
question of whether Wagner will
ultimately end up there which by the way
is still very much an open question and
the assertions about potential
deployments of nuclear weapons on the
territory of Belarus and the role of
Belarus in it and complicity of Belarus
in Russia's aggression in Ukraine these
are all things that we have been taking
account of going back to the start of
this conflict and we constantly look at
everything from the positioning of NATO
force to the pre-positioning of various
stocks and ammunition in the Eastern
flank that will be a continued
discussion at Vilnius but this is an
evolving picture and so I don't think
Vilnius is going to be the place where
we put the final storyline down it will
continue to evolve as we go forward well
thanks Jake
does the U.S support eliminating the
need for Ukraine to fulfill a membership
action plan that essentially establishes
benchmarks they have to meet to qualify
for Native membership so we're looking
at that question uh that is an active
discussion among allies right now
whether Ukraine has in fact moved beyond
the need for map I won't get ahead of
where leaders will end up at the summit
but that's under active consideration uh
just uh one on on a bilap with the
erdogan is is this going to be a pull
aside that the president is planning to
have or will this be like a full blown
bilateral meeting to discuss Sweden's
NATO membership I don't have anything to
announce today but I think you can
expect that President Biden and
president erdogan will talk in Vilnius
in exactly exactly what format that
takes remains to be seen two questions
um first on the Munitions um Germany has
opposed them does that suggest any
cracks of the alliances to you what do
you make of that opposition so first
what I saw at Germany say today was
three things number one uh they're
confident that the United States took
this decision carefully and after
weighing all considerations number two
Russia has used these in an intolerable
way to attack Ukraine and three every
weapon system Ukraine is using it's
using to defend its people and to retake
its own Sovereign territory I think if
you read what the German Chancery and
the German spokesperson put out today
you will see that they are a signatory
to Oslo
they don't uh transfer they don't have
or transfer cluster Munitions but
nothing in what they have said today
suggests there are any cracks in NATO
Unity quite the contrary there's deep
understanding We Believe across the
alliance about the fundamental challenge
Ukraine faces and about our Collective
desire to ensure that we're providing
Ukraine with what it needs
specifically please can you tell us
specifically when the president signed
the authorization and also we have seen
over the course of this war how there
were some no-go topics f-16s cluster
Munitions both of those are moving
forward is there a line where the U.S
won't cross obviously the president has
said no U.S Personnel inside uh Ukraine
is there some other limit or does this
suggest to president zielinski that
whatever he needs ultimately he will get
the president has been very clear from
the very beginning of this conflict
about two things that have been
unwavering first the United States is
not going to war with Russia in Ukraine
and second the United States is not
providing weapons to Ukraine to attack
Russia we do not encourage or enable
attacks on Russian territory from
Ukraine the question of weapon systems
has evolved as the conflict has evolved
that those two fundamental precepts
have been true from the start they
remain true today and they will be true
tomorrow as well I can't give you the
exact specifics on that but because you
know I'll let the internal processes
kind of have their have their sanctity
but
um he approved it as they said after a
uh unanimous recommendation from his
National Security team
um you said that NATO is stronger than
ever at this point what does it say that
there are two NATO members who have been
holding up Sweden's ability to join the
alliance for the more than a year now
so the last NATO Ally to come into the
alliance before Finland I believe it was
Montenegro and I think it took something
like 19 months for them to come in
uh I think a lot of people's perceptions
about the accession process have been
shaped by just how fast we moved to get
Sweden and Finland ratified here in the
United States on a bipartisan basis how
fast Finland came in
and then how it has only been a year uh
since Sweden sought membership and we
are confident that Sweden will come in
in the not too distant future and that
there will be unanimous uh support for
that and then I would go beyond that to
say in terms of what it says about NATO
strength
here you have two historically
non-aligned countries
who for decades did not join NATO
seeking to join NATO I think there is no
clearer indication of the strength
attraction and cohesion of NATO than
that yeah
um so I understand your point about
reforms that Ukraine still needs to
its membership also your point on map
but just going kind of broader from that
my understanding is that the president
believes that a fast-track membership
for Ukraine is an invitation rather than
a deterrence to war with Russia he has
several times expresses concern for a
nuclear escalation can you first confirm
whether my understanding is correct and
if so can you explain the calculus
behind the president's position on that
what led him to that conclusion the
president has repeatedly said that there
is an Open Door that there is a pathway
for Ukraine and that Ukraine needs to
take additional reforms to complete its
work towards NATO membership that has
been his position from the beginning
that remains true today that will remain
true at Vilnius the President also has
been clear that we are going to support
Ukraine for as long as it takes and
provide them an exceptional quantity of
arms and capabilities both from
ourselves and facilitating those from
allies Partners but that we are not
seeking to start World War III that is
the course that we've been on since the
start of this conflict that is the
course we've remain on today and we
believe that we have been able to mount
a vigorous concerted effective Dynamic
response to Russia's aggression in
support of the brave people of Europe
former U.S officials have held secret
talks with Ukraine with prominent
Russians to lay the groundwork for a
negotiation towards a peace deal I
actually appreciate this question
because I think that the reporting
suggested something that in fact has not
happened
uh my understanding is there was a
meeting at the Council on Foreign
Relations with the foreign minister of
Russia that meeting did not include
participation from the United States
government the United States government
did not pass messages through that
meeting the United States government did
not seek to pursue diplomacy direct
indirect or otherwise through that
meeting period there are also contacts
between private American citizens and
Russians that has been happening not
just in the last year but for the last
75 years since time immemorial the
United States government is not using
any of those contacts to pass messages
to promote diplomacy direct indirect or
otherwise and any suggestion to the
contrary is simply untrue
Jack I have a few days
prime minister kishida with discussed
the issue of this charge of contaminate
the water at the
1970 this time do you know the already
know that yesterday iaea Secretary
General civility to South Korea and he
said that he will not take
responsibility for the discharge of
contaminated rewarders what is the
United States position on the iaea's
report on the discharge of contaminated
watering and I follow up segmentation
uh from our perspective the iaea
secretary General's report was based on
the professional analysis of the
competent International institution and
I'll leave it at that I would also say
that the ROK government made its own
statements and reactions to that which
we thought were quite constructive
[Music]
a new career conservative Guru movie
will be held in Seoul very soon and this
month do we have any content of this
meeting who will gonna be attending this
meeting I don't have anything to
announce today I will say though that I
spoke with my South Korean counterpart
last evening to discuss preparations for
that meeting it will be an important
meeting there will be high level
participation by the United States
because this is an important issue on
which we place priority and launching
the nuclear consultative group is a
specific outcome of the Washington
Summit between President Yoon and
President Biden an outcome of the
historic Washington declaration and you
will see in this meeting that we are
quite serious about taking this effort
forward last question thank you Jake
five days after cocaine was found here
in the White House Congressional
Republicans seem like they're very close
to launching some sort of formal
investigation I'm curious from a
national security perspective
wait what was your reaction when the
drugs were found and B was there any
risk to security either to the president
to your staff anybody that would work
out of the sit room for the stuff to be
so close to where you were
so first I would refer to the Secret
Service when it comes to questions of
the security of the president I won't
speak to that second I would make a
point about the situation room because I
think there's been a lot of questionable
reporting on this situation room is not
in use and has not been in use for
months because it is currently under
construction we are using an alternate
Situation Room in the Eisenhower
executive office building so the only
people coming in and going out of the
sit room in this period have been
workers who are getting it ready to go
by the way it's on time and on schedule
to be uh to be back on station here in
the not too distant future but no there
was no issue with the Situation Room
relative to this and then finally uh
look we have rigorous drug testing
policies at the White House we have
rigorous drug use policies here at the
White House we take those extremely
seriously so we'll let the investigation
unfold if it involves someone from the
White House the appropriate consequences
will ensue if it involves some visitor
who came in and left it then that's a
different matter that raises a different
set of questions that are less relevant
to my line of work so I will leave it at
that but I do not believe at present
as things stand here at the podium today
that we are facing some national
security threat uh uh ongoing national
security threat
yeah yeah exactly we're facing other
Nationals
yeah last one Secretary General
stoneberg said after his meeting
yesterday that there is good progress
towards sweeping joining NATO but there
are still gaps so how would you assess
the likelihood at this point of an
agreement on Sweden's NATO membership I
will make no predictions I will just say
that President Biden had the opportunity
to meet with the Swedish prime minister
here in Washington to express his
solidarity for with Sweden for its
application for membership we believe
that Sweden should be in NATO as soon as
possible and we would love to see it
happen if illness it is possible that it
does it is possible that it doesn't
happen until some period after but we
believe it will happen in the not too
distant future and that those gaps can
be closed everything can be resolved
that there is fundamentally Good Will
from all of the parties to get this done
it's a question of time and I can't
predict whether that will happen next
week or at some point in the ensuing
weeks and with that I said it was my
last question so thank you guys
thank you Jake thanks for coming
okay
um just have a couple things at the top
and I know that uh
there's an event with the president
shortly
so President Biden has made combating
the opioid crisis a key part of his
agenda and has taken decisive actions to
reduce both the supply of illicit
Fentanyl and negative Health outcomes
associated with illicit drugs today this
Administration is continuing to take
action and bringing together countries
from around the world to act
following through the commitment
President Biden made in Ottawa this year
today the Department of State brought
together more than 70 countries and
international organizations to launch
the global coalition to address
synthetic drug threats this effort will
continue to bring Global attention and
action to address the public health and
security threats posed by synthetic
drugs like illicit fentanyl and another
thing that I wanted to add as I just
mentioned we're going to go see the
president shortly for his event so um
as it relates to what he's going to
announce you heard the president talk
about binomics and how he's growing the
economy from the middle out and bottom
up not top down not the trickle-down uh
trigger down economics as we have seen
so this afternoon the president will
talk about new actions to further cut
costs for American families first we're
cracking down on junk Insurance new
proposed rules would would uh close
loopholes the previous administration
took advantage of that allow companies
to offer misleading insurance plans and
trick consumers into junk plans next
we're going to uh we're going to after
surprise medical bills we're going to go
after this after the surprise medical
bills under this Administration we've
taken action to prevent 1 million
surprise medical bills every month
today's new guidance prevents abuse of
those those protections
finally we're taking action to stop
unfair medical debt for the first time
in history the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau HHS and treasury are
looking into medical credit cards and
Loans to see if companies are adhering
to Consumer Protections and then later
today as well you'll hear from President
Biden on these new steps not later today
but in just like 30 minutes or so to
deliver on his promise to cut costs for
families that is really a big part of
what binomics is to make sure that we're
lowering costs for American families and
they'll show that we have an economy
that works for everyone this morning as
you all learned
209 000 jobs were created last month for
a total of 13.2 million jobs created
since President Biden took office we've
regained all the jobs lost during the
pandemic and created nearly 4 million
more jobs that includes over 1.5 million
jobs in manufacturing construction and
research and development the focus of
the president's investment in America
agenda you heard from the President
yesterday talking about of investing in
America and what he continues to do for
red States and blue States and for
Americans across the country as you all
know the unemployment rate is 3.6
percent and has been under four percent
for 16 months in a row the longest
stretch in over 50 years
and more Americans are joining the labor
for the labor force the share of working
age Americans who have jobs at the
highest level in over 20 years so as the
president said this morning and I quote
this is from his statement about the
jobs the jobs uh the jobs report I quote
that's by by nomics growing the economy
by creating jobs lowering costs for
hard-working families and making smart
investments in America
and finally this is something that we
wanted to address because we've all been
dealing with uh this uh this extreme
weather if you will the extreme hit and
so um conditions these conditions are
certainly impacting millions of
Americans across a country in different
regions clearly these extreme weather
patterns are alarming but for years for
years now Republicans lawmakers have
continued to deny the very existence of
climate change that we can now all
witness with our very own eyes so
they've repeatedly tried to repeal the
biggest climate protection bill in
history as you all know this is
something that the president signed
almost a year ago the inflation
reduction act and this is a act that is
the most significant investment that
that any Administration has put behind
climate change and so by them trying to
repeal this is it is stunning it is
absurd and it is dangerous just by what
we have seen these past couple of days
so as a senator as as a as now president
uh the president was one of the first
members of Congress to take real action
against climate change and he will
continue to charge forward on the most
ambitious climate agenda to date he is
investing in our nation's electric grid
and accelerating clean energy deployment
so we can reduce pollutants and bring
clean energy jobs and Manufacturing back
to America in the meantime Federal
officials are proactively inspecting
over 70 high-risk Industries in areas
under a heat warning or advisory to
protect workers and next week we'll be
announcing additional actions to protect
communities from extreme heat I do not
have a week ahead because you just heard
from the National Security advisor give
a very extensive and detail week ahead
of the president's trip and uh
in Europe at NATO Summit so I don't have
anything else to share beyond what he
shared with you all today go ahead Chris
uh one of these went out to stocks on
the job report is what is concerned that
it came in lower than expectations or
they do this as a it's a good thing
given that you know a cooling jumper may
be less inflation and less pressure to
raise rates how are you kind of engaging
that yeah no it's a good question it's
certainly not going to talk about
interest rates as you know that is
something for uh something for
um the FED to deal with and certainly we
we allow them to have their uh their
independence as it relates to any
monetary decisions that they have to
make but over the past three months
we've averaged about 244 000 jobs a
solid Pace a strong labor market and a
solid gain of at this point and the
economic expansion as we're looking at
especially the last two years and just
to quote what the president's wrote his
op-ed in a Wall Street Journal just last
May if average monthly job creation
shifts in the next year from current
levels of 500 000 to something closer to
150 it will be a sign that we are
successfully moving into the next phase
of recovery as this kind of job growth
is consistent with unemployment rate and
a healthy economy
Thanksgiving a quick question on the
jobs report as well total black employee
appointment is down three straight
months now with 635 000 jobs uh lost in
that spell which is the most ever in a
three month stretch outside of the
pandemic is that a setback for the
administration or do you have account so
I'll just remind you that uh under this
Administration back in April you saw the
the unemployment rate hit a record low
at 4.7 percent and that was just a
couple months ago again under this
Administration look this data certainly
particularly particularly is volatile
and that is something that we understand
so it's most useful to to measure in a
quarterly basis over three months
instead of one one to uh to smooth out
noise right because there is this one is
a little bit more noisy so um you know
the black jobless rate last quarter was
tied with the previous quarter for the
lowest lowest on the record so that is
also important to note so this is why we
continue to say how important binomics
is uh how how it has actually were
worked for all Americans not leaving
anyone behind when you think about more
black Americans are employed in the
labor force when you think about more
black Americans have health care with
average of almost 50 percent in
healthcare.gov coverage we achieve the
fastest rate of new black owned
businesses in over 25 years we're
investing in infrastructure in
communities of color that are normally
left behind that are normally not taken
into consideration and so we're
reconnecting that's reconnecting those
communities that are separated and we're
closing the digital divide for black
Americans because of the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation when you
think about Broadband so all of these
things are part of some of comes out of
a part of the president's key signature
pieces of legislation that clearly are
until in law and into law now and that
we're implementing so there are uh there
there is an effort to make sure that we
continue to do the bottom-up middle out
and not do this trickle-down economy
these numbers a cause for concern or are
you looking at any as a blip because it
is these are so what I said was this
that is particularly vulnerable so we
have to make sure that we we look at it
more holistic more holistically because
it's a vulnerable data but there are
also data points that I just pointed to
right that show that under this
Administration we have seen record low
uh unemployment when you think about the
black community 4.7 ever ever since we
started tracking uh unemployment rate in
different communities so that matters
and so that's why the president
continues to talk about binomics and
continues to implement some again some
of these key historic pieces of
legislation that is going to help
communities uh like in the in the black
community
three
um the president this week tapped Gene
Sperling to lead talks between Auto
Workers and the big three auto
manufacturers who is the White House's
Point person to over the strike uh with
UPS workers so as it relates to the UPS
UPS look we are
and I say this all the time the
represent the president respects
Collective Barney bargaining and he
respects that process he believes an
agreement negotiated between the parties
involved is the best possible solution
so we're going to remain optimistic
we're going to certainly remain to uh to
make to to be consistent in how we see
this I don't have any information on
increased Administration involvement but
certainly we remain in contact with both
parties
specific point person from the White
House just don't have anything I don't
have a specific point person but we of
course are in touch with both parties
and then what are you guys developing in
terms of potential contingency plans uh
because this UPS strike if it happens
would have massive implications across
the country it's understood that FedEx
and USPS would not be able to handle all
of the packages that UPS handles if the
strike goes forward so is there anything
the White House is doing to prepare for
that possibility at the end of the month
so look we understand these types of
contract negotiations can be you know
could be tough it could be contentious
we get that and so we're going to
continue to remain
optimistic as these conversations
continue to occur uh work as I mentioned
we're in touch with both parties just
don't have anything else to lay out as
far as a plan later now does the White
House have any plans to play threats
does the White House have any plans to
join threats oh right
um uh I don't have anything to preview
on that for you I need to I'm I'm
curious about it as well I mean I just
don't have anything to prove you on that
but I know that it is getting some
attention out there oh God
why didn't the president attend the
king's coronation
you mean that happened a couple months
ago yes why why didn't he attend I think
we were I think we addressed this I
think they we mentioned that he had a
call with the King uh and congratulated
him and they said that they would uh
they would get together later on and
they are that's what you're going to see
early this week I don't think there's
there's I don't there's no there there
they're going to see each other in a
couple of days and I think that's a good
thing so initially you also described it
as a state visit but this isn't a state
visit so what happens there uh I mean
I'm not gonna get into specifics of what
this is going to be called I think
what's important is that the president's
going to go to London he's going to go
to the UK we you know we have a long
history with the United Kingdom with the
people of the United Kingdom and I think
it's important that the president's
going to go out there and he's going to
have a meeting with not just the king
but also the Prime Minister and I think
that's what you're going to see
continuing a partnership with the United
Kingdom and I think that's important
has the president been kept updated on
the cargo ship fire in New Jersey as he
talked to Governor Murphy about this
yeah um which is uh clearly uh
devastating the president certainly has
been uh kept uh kept updated on what uh
on what's been going on with the cargo
ship at Port Newark and so we've been in
touch with the Coast Guard and local
authorities to coordinate on the
response obviously our hearts go out to
the families of the firefighters who
lost lives in the line of duty while
bravely battling this fire and our
thoughts are with those who suffered
injuries and we wish them a certainly a
speedy recovery and we're going to
continue to monitor the situation
closely this incident and stand ready to
provide as much assistance as needed to
help contain the fire and get Port
operations of back to normal but
certainly our heart goes out to the
firefighters and their their families
there was a report that according to the
head of the firefighters Union the
president called the families of Fallen
firefighters to offer his personal
condolences can you confirm I don't have
any calls to confirm as you know the
president that is not unusual for the
president to call families especially in
these types of awful awful tragedies I
just don't have anything to confirm at
this time
secretary yellin said in China that she
wants China to play by a fair set of
rules so how can the White House make a
country that engages in IP theft forced
labor hacking to play by a fair set of
rules
look um
that relationship right that is what's
important here with New Economic
leadership team in place in Beijing it
comes at a key Junction for the global
economy and so we think it's important
to continue to have these conversations
with with China with other countries as
well look they're going to continue and
I've said this before China is going to
continue to be around and be a major
player on the world stage so it is
important to have intense competition
requires intense diplomacy that's what
you see secretary yellin do that's what
you saw secretary blinken do these are
the type of conversation that the
president has had with President XI and
meetings that he's had with him as well
and it is uh it is important to uh to to
manage this in a responsible way and so
we're we think it's also important to
continue the open line of communications
as we have said over and over again and
as it relates to the economy global
economy having the Secretary of Treasury
there in China as we talk about again
global economy I think is incredibly
important and the president believes
it's incredibly important you want to
get the task about the United Auto
Workers who are asking the EPA to soften
the electric vehicle rules is that
something that the administration would
consider so as it relates to the UAW
look again collective bargaining that's
something that the president
is believes is really important I think
so I think you were mentioning to me
Jeremy was mentioning jeans Gene
Sperling who is certainly playing a role
here is one of the White House Point
person on key issues related to the UAW
the administration's rule to get people
into electric vehicles though I hear you
I'm not going to get no I hear I'm not
going to get into specifics I'm just
letting you know that as Gene Sperling
certainly has been a contact here and
we'll ensure that the
administration-wide coordination across
interested parties and among white house
policy makers their conversation
continues and we work hand in glove with
the acting secretary as well of Labor
and I just don't have anything else to
to share beyond that but certainly we
have someone who is coordinating helping
to coordinate some of these
conversations I'm just not going to get
ahead of that
great thank you
so that giving cluster Munitions to
Ukraine undermines America's reputation
as a human rights Defender around the
world what's the White House response I
mean we don't believe that that that it
undermines our our uh our reputation of
Being Human Rights offenders this is
something that we say all the time right
when it comes to human rights when it
comes to having those conversations with
either our partners or other heads of
state we certainly the president has
never shies away from having those
conversations look I mean Jake said this
when he was here we have to remember
what's happening in Ukraine right
Ukraine is defending itself it's
defending its freedom it's defending its
Sovereign territory and that is what we
are doing here we're making sure that
they are able to do that Russia this is
a war that Russia started this is an
aggression by Russia and so we have seen
by you know bipartisan support and what
we're trying to do in helping Ukraine
fighting for their freedom and I think
we'll continue to do to see that but as
I come comes to Human Rights the
president will always be very clear and
have very honest conversations with our
partners and other other heads of States
across across the world thank you um
digital mentioned that into this
decision about class terminations after
Consulting with Dallas so I wanted to
see if you could provide some details
about a if their money was consulted or
call them what countries but I'm not
going to go into each country that was
consulted but clearly those are some of
our allies correct and so uh I'm just
not going to get into details but
certainly the president did consult our
allies and partners here look when you
look at the last 16 months of this war
that we saw that this Russia aggression
in Ukraine we have seen a NATO alliance
that has been strengthened because of
the leadership of this President we've
seen bipartisanship here we have seen
Europe come together the West come
together to make sure that we do
everything that we can to help Ukraine
fight for its freedom and so that is
really important we got to remember
what's at stake here what's at stake is
democracy and so the president is going
to do everything that we can to help the
people of Ukraine fight for those
freedoms good
about assistance in terms of the
security side today but should we also
expect any commitments on the
humanitarian side with next week either
to those in Exile in Lithuania or
refugees in Poland that's a very good
questions only I don't have anything to
preview for you at this time but
certainly humanitarian Aid is something
that we have provided in the past or and
have certainly put that as an important
and important assistant to provide I
just don't have anything that's going to
come out of the NATO Summit this week
I'm sure that we will be providing
information as we go through the days I
just don't have anything for you at this
time
hi
um I'm wondering if you have any
comments about recent crime in DC's it's
raising rates we've lost an SIV
applicant from Afghanistan in the most
recent killings
um really tragic wondering if the White
House has to say about that and then
secondly
um sorry to bring out cocaine again but
um there was a question yesterday during
press Gaggle with um Andrew Bates that
was I guess
he said that it had he did he was
avoiding it because of the hatchback I'm
just asking again can we just named once
and for all whether or not the cocaine
belonged to the Biden family so
right
a couple of things there
um
he mentioned the Hatch Act because the
question was posed to him in the Donald
in using Donald Trump and so he was
trying to be very mindful
okay I hear you but you're asking me a
question so I'm answering it for you
um and so that's why he said the
hatchback so I would I would you know
have you read the transcript and read
the transcript fully so you can see
exactly what he was trying to say so
that's number one so we're not avoiding
the question that is not true we've
answered this question litigated this
question for the last two days
exhaustively
um you know there has been some
irresponsible reporting about the family
and uh and so I gotta call that out here
and I have been very clear I was clear
two days ago when talking about this
over and over again as I wasn't being
asked a question as you know in media
Outlets reported this the buying family
was not here they were not here
they were at Camp David they were not
here Friday they were not here Saturday
they were not here Sunday they were not
even here Monday they came back on
Tuesday so to ask that question is
actually incredibly irresponsible
and and um
I'll just leave it there okay
okay I'll take one more good straight
straight right here yep given the U.S
Supreme Court's decision last week on
affirmative action I'm interested the
president has a stance on whether
Congress should take action ban Legacy
uh conferences in higher education
admissions uh I don't have anything
further to to add uh on the president's
position on what you just laid out what
I can say is and the president said this
he gave a full-throated uh kind of
remarks on what he saw
the Supreme Court do which was
unprecedented which is as you all know
this was uh this was when you think
about affirmative action it had been a
constitutional
um kind of kind of constitutional right
for decades and had been held up by
Republicans and Democrats and so it was
another uh kind of a another act by the
Supreme Court that was unprecedented
when you think about the dubs Dobbs
decision and now this and so let's not
forget the president uh was when he was
Senator he was the chair of the
Judiciary Committee and he understand he
has the expertise he understands how
this all works uh and it is incredibly
unfortunate what we saw last week I will
say this one of the things that the
president has taken very seriously is to
make sure that we have federal judges
that are diverse that represent the
country we have we have been able to not
just nominate but get through about 136
judges again who are diverse and he had
make he's made that one of his top
priorities as we uh as we look at what's
going on with this uh the Supreme Court
currently all right everybody thank you
so much I'll see some of you in at NATO
thank you